tudo começou na minha vida
aos três anos de idade morava em natal e
queria mostrar pra vocês como as pessoas
podem se motivar a transformar suas
vidas o que motiva alguém quando nasce
viver respirar mas o agir também outra
coisa importante que as pessoas precisam
entender que a emoção é a força motriz
na vida de qualquer um
e aos três anos de idade a vida me
pregou a primeira emoção a primeira peça
quando eu morava na rua nações unidas
nas quintas e meu pai foi embora de casa
deixando a minha mãe em três filhos e
mais duas mulheres sozinhos abandonados
minha mãe não tinha emprego minha mãe
não tinha pensão minha mãe não tinha
profissão a minha mãe não tinha
absolutamente nada com seu amor
naquele momento a vida estava me
mostrando uma situação que eu não
conhecia e fomos à luta vamos à luta
vamos buscar uma inovação oscar uma
sobrevivência o que aconteceu comigo eu
simplesmente sobreviver a este problema
com a minha mãe e as duas irmãs quando
naquele momento a nossa vida de fome era
coisa constante eu passei várias vezes
dois dias sem comer absolutamente nada
mas aí a mãe junto com minhas duas irmãs
junto comigo também passava de uma forma
muito grande eu disse minha mãe eu vou
trabalhar com você e saímos vendendo de
porta em porta nas ruas do tirol copo de
lagoa seca alecrim nas ruas de nova
descoberta morro branco nas ruas de
natal até que um dia depois de muitas
lutas de muitas batalhas 17 e 18 anos
entrei na maioria foi para o rio de
janeiro
quando cheguei no rio eu tinha que morar
dentro do quartel para poder levar
mandar o dinheiro para minha família
para que pudessem levar a vida mais uma
oportunidade que a vida me deu para
crescimento
o sofrimento nos traz crescimento e eu
busquei mais uma vez seguir na vida e
contra uma mulher
casei com ela estou até hoje a grande
escapada que está do meu lado
dando a grande escola muleta comecei a
ganhar algum dinheiro ea primeira coisa
que eu fiz quando comecei a ganhar meu
primeiro dever não foi comprar um carro
foi comprar uma casa para minha mãe
quando eu comprei a casa para minha mãe
e depois eu comecei a ver e enxergar que
outras mães precisava de outras casas
outras pessoas também precisava de
outras casas de te ajudar aquelas
velhinhas mas não conseguia porque eu
não queria eu queria comprar uma casa
pra colocar uma briga não tenha
condições o que foi que eu fiz me juntei
porque sozinho não conseguiria mas
busquei uma alguma instituição e
descobrir o lar da vovozinha aqui em
natal
quando eu descobri um lado a vovozinha
eu comecei a ir uma vez por mês lá
depois passei uma vez por semana e
depois eu comecei a me doar muito mais
conseguia minhas palestras pelo brasil
inteiro nas grandes empresas
eu sempre pedia que as pessoas no 10 nos
dessem fraldas e medicamentos vitaminas
para que aquelas vozes pudessem ter uma
vida melhor e nós ficamos como
voluntário vários anos lá na casa
o meu negócio da banca foi crescendo eu
fui ganhando um pouco de notoriedade na
banca a banca foi se colocando melhor
até o ponto que eu disse
existe algo que eu possa fazer melhor e
comecei a tentar fazer algumas campanhas
para o lar da vovozinha
fazemos todo final de mês na minha banca
uma ação social um trabalho de marketing
para que eu pudesse ganhar dinheiro mas
também para mostrar a necessidade que
essas linhas tinham que algumas são
abandonadas
outras são colocadas lá pelos filhos
pelos parentes não são visitadas e aí
depois disso
depois de muito tempo lá a criança lá
tenta criança que dormir aí dentro de
mim acordou e decidiu se precisa fazer
algo pelas crianças também não tinha
recursos como a maioria não tem mas eu
tenho a vontade eu sabia que sozinho não
conseguiria nada mas eu juntar se alguém
iria conseguir algumas coisas
um exemplo da vovozinha estava muito
presente na minha vida
aí o que aconteceu eu fui a são paulo e
recebeu o diploma de doutor honoris
causa da academia paulista de letras da
fundação uma fundação
bem de educação em são paulo eu recebi
um diploma de doutor honoris causa pelo
empreendedorismo só de dinheiro não para
empreendedorismo social porque a partir
de uma banca de revistas de seis por
três com um funcionário apenas eu estava
conseguindo fazer alguma coisa
fazendo bem o aqui para o bem das
pessoas
as pessoas chegavam lá os flanelinhas
quando chegavam flanelinhas e eu quero
trabalhar na banca a primeira coisa que
eu fazia não quero você flanelinha pega
a camisa da minha banca vai pra casa
tome banho amanhã chegue tomado banho
com o cabelo arrumado que lhe pago x
reais por semana
e aquele garoto dizia você tem que
entregar pra você ganhar dinheiro o seu
boletim escolar
ele só recebia o dinheiro se me
mostrasse o boletim escolar ser
estudasse porque eu sei que a única
forma de transformar as pessoas é o
estudo é pela educação
e aí alguns voltavam a cada dez que
chegava lá apenas um voltavam
depois disso eu comecei a fazer a
corrente do bem
cada livro que eu lia eu comecei a ler
muito cada livro que eu li eu colocava
na contracapa
faça como eu leia e passe à frente e
colocava meu e mail
já recebi informações de pessoas em ijuí
no rio grande do sul
jussiê muito obrigado pela oportunidade
de ler este livro você conseguiu que eu
lesse um livro que era meu sonho
gratuitamente é a corrente é simples é
só aqui para o bem e agora que nós
podemos fazer
depois disso eu queria trabalhar com
crianças e não conseguia abrir uma casa
mas eu me associei busquei pesquisei e
encontrei aqui em ponta negra não sei
que uma casa fantástica que tem uma
escola chamada escola do futuro porque
eu queria fazer a mudança na cabeça e na
vida das pessoas
a mudança nós podemos fazer qualquer um
pode fazer basta querer transformar o
invisível no visível também podemos
transformar sonhos em realidade como
usando a vontade a emoção do que fazer
eu conheci a escola do caminho ea escola
do caminho começou a entrar na minha
vida eu comecei a ir novamente uma vez
por mês depois uma vez por semana
depois duas vezes por semana ea escola
do caminho
nós pegamos pessoas crianças nós temos
quase 100 crianças lá que estão abaixo
da linha da pobreza eles não têm alguns
não têm par e não têm pais
alguns têm parentes alguns não têm os
pais mas eles não podem pagar uma creche
eles deixam as crianças lá aqui no
conjunto ponta negra vão trabalhar no
final do dia eles pegam as crianças
alimentadas educadas e uma coisa
importante não é só o alimento material
não é só a educação é sim o amor
vivenciado durante as oito horas que
eles passam com a gente
é uma lição de cidadania que nós
proporcionamos aquelas crianças que
quando ela chegou na vila de ponta negra
elas passam o amor que elas absorveram
na nossa casa
as suas famílias ela se transforma numa
grande célula do amor uma grande célula
do conhecimento de alguns pais nos
procuram dizendo assim você não sabe
como minha filha mudou
você não sabe como meu filho está
transformado e nós cada vez mais
queremos doar mais amor mais carinho
mais conhecimento essas crianças
nós recebemos doações de livros quando
só nós entregamos a outras escolas mais
carentes do que a nossa
a escola do caminho carece de tudo menos
de amor amor transborda lá e nós estamos
o tempo todo
sintonizados para saber da nossa
responsabilidade
quando nós queremos ajudar aqui é assim
que faz qualquer um que está aqui nessa
sala pode fazer qualquer um cidadão pode
fazer qualquer uma pessoa por mais pobre
que seja financeiramente não tem
dinheiro mas tem movido não tem dinheiro
tem um ombro não tem dinheiro tem a mão
para apertar tem um abraço pra qual é
acolher às vezes as pessoas não precisa
só de objetos só de coisas materiais é
preciso da tua companhia
e aqui tá uma fotografia da hora que
eles estão almoçando nosso na nossa
escola do caminho são 106 crianças até 8
anos de idade e para que vocês possam
ter uma idéia a felicidade dessas
crianças amanhã não precisa avisar um
dia para visitar qualquer
o que vocês quiserem podem conhecer é
assim o nosso desafio do dia a dia é
assim que nós mostramos que a meta a
gente busca o caminho a gente acha o
desafio a gente enfrenta
sabe por que algumas pessoas quando eu
procuro algumas pessoas até desviar o
caminho quando me contundi de encontro a
mim porque sabe que eu vivo com o pires
na mão pedindo as coisas para as pessoas
uma coisa importante que eu vi quando
alguém desvia é porque há sintonia dele
ainda não chegou para entender que aqui
se faz o bem e quando você quer
transformar a vida tão fácil
olha o desafio que eu vou colocar pra
vocês o ano tem 365 dias
concordam em 12 meses
concordam se tem 12 meses se você tira
um dia um dia por mês
som para ajudar o irmão uma casa de
caridade um abrigo de idosos só um serão
apenas 12 dias por ano
se o ano tem 365 dias
se você tirar 12 para o irmão sobrar pra
você 353 dias e 12 dias para o irmão
será que nós estamos fazendo
será que nós estamos deixando para
depois portanto o sonho a gente realiza
e o sonho eu realizo quando eu quero
fazer
quando eu posso fazer e quando eu faço
acontecer a vida ela nos prega peças à
vida nos dá oportunidades mas acima de
qualquer coisa a emoção de desfrutar da
alegria de uma criança com alegria de um
idoso que está acalentado bem amado bem
acolhido e bem servido isso não tem
preço o aqui para o bem
somos nós que fazemos muito obrigado
[Aplausos]